okay so i guess we can start the
afternoon session which will consist of
three talks the first of which will be
by sally shrapnel by from the university
of queensland and she will talk about
causal discovery in the quantum context
thank you julia
thank you to
thomas and fred and the organizers for
inviting me to give this talk i'm really
very grateful to be able to be here and
particularly grateful to be able to be
here in person my university
gave permission for staff members to
travel literally two weeks ago so i was
it was very touch and go there for a
while i thought i was going to have to
do this by zoom but i'm very glad to
have been able to come it's been a
really terrific interdisciplinary
workshop
i've enjoyed talking to philosophers and
economists and statisticians and
biostatisticians i've learned an awful
lot about classical causal modelling and
and causal inference it's been really
very useful for me
um so i am aware that this is uh the
third talk that you've seen this week on
quantum causal models
um and there is a fair bit of overlap
between the talks that eric gave and and
john gave in the talk that i'm giving
but i thought that i would try and come
at it from a different perspective and
that is i'm really speaking to the
people in the audience who know nothing
about quantum
so the idea is that i will try
i will try as best i can
at the end of the talk hopefully you'll
have a bit of an intuitive idea
as how the quantum causal model works
maybe some practical examples of where
it would be useful
but most importantly i'm hoping at the
end that that you may see some
opportunities and avenues for being able
to contribute
um to this field
so uh first of all i'll just be giving a
little brief overview of the problems
that we have when we try and apply
classical calls and methodology just
kind of prima facie to to correlations
and we've seen this so we saw it in
tim's talk a bit and we saw it in eric's
talk and and
we have seen this to some extent so i'll
go through this fairly quickly but i'm
just giving my two bits worth on on the
way that i see the kind of two key
problems
then i'll be talking about um a
particular quantum calls and modelling
framework which is work that i did with
fabio costa in 2015
and then we'll be talking about progress
on quantum causal discovery algorithms
now a bit of a spoiler alert so i know
that in the classical causal modeling
there's a vast taxonomy of causal
discovery algorithms you've got score
based methods and constraint based
methods and
i think daniel gave was like four hours
worth of tutorials or six hours or
something so we're going to get through
quantum calls or discovery in about 15
minutes there's one algorithm that's
been
written um and then there's a couple of
kind of
exploratory avenues that people are are
exploring but this field is wide open
there's a lot of things and um and so i
will be ending up really with with more
open questions than anything and
hopefully you will see some avenues for
where you can contribute
so what are the problems um well
typically we we come at the at
understanding the problems with applying
classical causal discovery methods and
quantum experiments from the bell
experiment and as you know you start off
with entangled particles you send them
to labs to very far apart space like
separated labs
and then you have a choice at either lab
of doing one of two measurements and
each of those measurements you get a
binary outcome
and that binary outcome is random
and if you set up the experiment so that
when you choose the measurement option
whether you do measurement one or two
here and measurement one or two over
here if you randomize that
then you get these
independences so the settings are
marginally independent because you're
just randomizing them and then you have
this no signaling
conditional independence so that is the
outcome on one wing is independent of
the setting on the other wing given the
setting on your own wing
and thank goodness for this in a way
because if we did have you know the
faster than light signaling and and you
know
everything would change like really
everything would change so in a way the
no signaling in some senses um
uh
you know um
saves you from some some i guess
difficult questions
uh
so the problem is when you when you plug
in these conditional independences and
when you think about the kind of
constraint based methods
you can show that you can't produce an
explanation of the dag that's both
markov and faithful
now
uh tim talked about
unfaithfulness and maybe unfaithfulness
is okay and i remember earlier in the
week someone said you know we accept
unfaithful explanations all the time in
in the classical world
when there's feedback mechanisms when
there's homeostatic mechanisms and we're
just not sampling at a rate that's fast
enough then unfaithfulness is something
that we are
willing to accept it obviously causes
problems for causal discovery
but the problem in the bell scenario is
that the the um fine tuning comes with a
whole lot of other problems so if you're
going to posit these kinds of fine
tuning to make sure that your
conditional independence holds then
you've either got to accept that
causal influence can travel faster than
the speed of light yet somehow we can't
use it to signal we can't actually get
hold of variables and control them
or you need to posit retrocausal
explanations or
accept super determinism
and there's a lovely paper i i really
like the paper by clark glenmore that he
wrote about this i think if you if you
haven't really fully understood the
weight of the bell correlations that's a
really good paper to start with
so the second problem
is the fact that we don't have this
really lovely distinction between
interventions and observations
in quantum systems so typically in the
classical causal modelling world you
know we we have this thing where like if
you've got all the interventions if you
can do all the interventions then
recovering the causal daggers is somehow
easier and
and typically what we we hear is well
there are situations where interventions
are unethical or they're difficult or
they're expensive and therefore we
resign to doing causal modelling when
you only have this passive observational
data
it's very difficult in the quantum
setting to understand what passive
observation means so
you know there are many ways that you
can see this but
i for one accept the fact that quantum
systems just do not possess objective
properties that can be assigned prior to
and independently of the active
measurement and it's not as simple as as
just that while it's just ignorance and
if we could measure it somehow more
precisely we'd be able to understand
what was going on it's much more
complicated than that
um you can look at the literature on
contextuality you can delve into aspects
of the heisenberg uncertainty principle
and look at it in various physical
situations you can go to the ontological
models framework there's lots of
literature out there to help you explore
that question
and for my talk i'm not going to explore
that question i'm just going to accept
that that is a problem that we we don't
have this ability to do passive
observations
there is of course
you know people sometimes say well you
know you can prepare something in
eigenstate of an observable and then you
can know with certainty what the outcome
is so if i went to julia who's an
experimentalist and said julia can you
please you know prepare me a quantum
system in a state you know that's an
eigenstate of a zero outcome she can
give me that and i know with certainty
if i measure that system i will get a
zero outcome with certainty but the
thing is if if that was all you could
ever do if you could only ever
you know prepare systems in eigenstates
of observables and measure them in that
basis you wouldn't see the kind of
correlations that we find interesting in
quantum systems
so again i said set that aside
so i think this leaves us with a really
interesting puzzle so on the one hand it
seems like we can't shoehorn
quantum correlations into our
understanding of classical causation
but yet there are growing armies of
quantum engineers all around the world
who are building really sophisticated
devices that are made of components that
they can exchange
they can intervene and change these
components they can make counter factual
statements if i put my if i turn my
laser to this instead of this here's how
the outcome would have changed if i put
a beam splitter instead of a half wave
plate this is what would have happened
so there is a sense in which quantum
engineers are already using causal
language and and making causal decisions
and perhaps even having causal
explanations
so i've just put these three examples up
these pictures are from um the
university of queensland where i work
this is dr sarah lau here on the left
she's a i'm an experimentalist who's um
she's now postdoc and and has uh is
working with a quantum optic set up
there
that stopped to catch alexander down in
the left-hand side
she was also a phd student with us and
she built the world's very first quantum
light microscope
so when you use light
to try and
look at a sample if you want to improve
your resolution you have to turn the
power up and if you turn it up
eventually you'll fry the sample that's
not good but you can use quantum light
so that you can have incredible
resolution at very very low power and
that's enabling us to see biological
samples now at a resolution that we've
never seen before so catch and the team
are there
working with that microscope the top
left hand picture there is 100 microns
wide
and that's professor helena
ribenstein-dunlop and her team has
created a bose-einstein condensate which
they can control such that they can make
these beautiful little pictures
of whatever they want it was a kangaroo
or the mona lisa but i thought i'd stick
with the gender theme for that uh
picture
um
anyway so
so thinking about that led us to develop
these quantum calls and models
and really at the most abstract level
these quantum models are just what
quantum engineers do and use all the
time
and you might think well what's the
point there's already people out there
using this kind of framework why why do
we need to call it causal models and why
do we need to kind of explore this and
but really it's the same as in the
classical case it's really nice having
an abstract formalism that's independent
of the platform that you use so whether
you're using superconducting qubits or
photons or this kind of application it
should be agnostic
so just as in classical world you can
you can use causal models in economics
or you can use them in medicine we want
that kind of agnostic framework
and so
what i'm going to present is based on
the paper that fabio and i wrote um if
you're interested in philosophy i wrote
a kind of philosophy version and the
british general philosophy of science
there um and then if you want the really
wordy version there's my phd somewhere
on the internet
right so
when you construct a quantum causal
framework there are two principles that
that we wanted to retain
the first one is this principle of
independent causal mechanisms and this
is a quote from the elements of causal
inference a textbook that i love which
says the causal generative process of a
system's variables is composed of
autonomous modules that don't inform or
influence each other
so you have this idea you know that the
edges in your dags they don't they don't
affect each other they're somehow
independent and there's this kind of
lego block idea of the way you build
causal structures so you might have a
joint probability but it will always
decompose into these sets of of
conditional dependences
and that these conditional independences
are
due to these independent causal
mechanisms so we're going to try and
retain that kind of principle
and we also want to retain the principle
that says that we have to allow the
possibility of causal discovery through
local intervention so i don't want to be
positing things that i can't do
experiments to uncover
i don't want to be positing potential
causal influences where there is some in
principle reason why i can never see
them okay
uh and these two kind of in a way give
you the fact that all correlations need
to be explained causally
so
this this is kind of the summary slide
for the mathematics of quantum causal
modelling you really only need two
equations right
there's this one
which is the causal structure so w is
the process matrix it's a matrix and it
will give you ultimately what the causal
structure is because it factorizes into
tensor product factors and each of those
factors represents a causal mechanism
and the other equation is how do i
attach probabilities to this story
because ultimately you know we're
working with correlations and so the
bottom equation says the probability
of a set of events occurring at each of
your nodes
is given by this formula and we'll
unpack that okay so ultimately what
we're going to be getting to is these
two so that you understand what these
two equations are
it's a very general formalism
so you associate you can think of the
nodes as kind of space-time regions
where you perform your interventions and
so for example a might be you know alice
in a lab here in berkeley and b might be
cindy in a lab in sydney and let's say
alice and cindy are
performing quantum operations in their
labs and then they're sending
information to each other quantum
information let's say via a photon an
entangled photon something like that
so the nodes can actually represent
those kind of spatial locations where
you do your interventions and the edges
can actually be the the system kind of
traversing and passing on information
from one node to another
you can also actually think of them in a
in a kind of more um in a smaller sense
in that they could be uh gates in a
quantum computer or little elements in a
quantum computer just anywhere where you
can make a change or perform an
intervention
can account for the nodes
so i'll start with the circuit model and
i thought long and hard about where i
should start and i think really the
circuit model is an easy place to start
because it's often now where people get
introduced to quantum theory
so all the big companies like google and
ibm and and microsoft if you go to their
quantum page now they will all have
introductory tutorials for people
computer scientists statisticians people
who know nothing about quantum they're
really good introductory tutorials and
they always start off with the circuit
model
this is the kind of the bible of quantum
information um it's a fantastic book you
read the first three chapters of that
book and you understand all the maths
that you need to know to understand
quantum calls and modelling it's all
kind of linear algebra and discrete
hilbert spaces
um
so the circuit model it's very similar
to a classical circuit model you prepare
a state um can be a bit you know a
single bit if you're in classical
computing but if you're in quantum
computing it's a qubit can be in a zero
one or a superposition of those and then
you perform logic gates they can be
single um qubit logic gates or two qubit
logic gates or as many as you like and
so the main difference is you have these
um is there a pointer oh you have the
the entangling gate so the the u with
the lambda on it is a gate that's
entangling those two qubits and at the
end you perform a measurement okay
so there is a um obviously an
idealization going on here and that is
that
the wire represents the identity channel
so that is you you know you start with a
system you prepare it you then wait a
bit and perform your gate and when
you're waiting a bit you don't want
anything to change so that's obviously
why we represent it with the identity
channel and all the gates can be
represented with unit tree operators
okay so unitary operator just a unitary
matrix
so what we want when we go to the causal
modeling
formalism at the very least as we kind
of need to be able to represent we need
some mathematical object that can
represent these kind of operations so
preparations measurements unitaries
um and so what we do is we use
completely positive maps
so when you think of events in a
classical causal model you think of a
random variable where the values give
you all the possibility space for you
know the modeling that you're doing in
the quantum case we have a kind of
different notion of an event and that is
all the available information that's
available to you at that space
spatiotemporal location
and we resent represent them
mathematically by completely positive
maps
so these cp maps will map operators
positive operators over the input space
of your node to operators over the
output space of your node and you index
them by both the choice of your quantum
instrument i'll get to that in a sec and
also the respective outcome
now
i i realized after speaking to some
people after eric's talk that we use the
word instrument all the time and in our
quantum talks it's nothing to do with
instrumental variables like it's it's
it's a completely technical quantum term
all it means is it's a set of completely
positive maps that sum together to be
trace preserving and the way you can
think of it is so you know when we think
of the bell experiment you've got alice
and bob and alice can choose one of two
measurements
that measurement choice is a quantum
instrument
and you describe the two outcomes so
when she chooses one particular
measurement she'll get one of two
outcomes each of those outcomes can be
associated with a completely positive
map
so for each of those measurement choices
the two cp maps can sum together to be a
completely positive trace preserving map
and the trace preserving property is
kind of like normalization it just
ensures with with probability one that
you're going to get something you know
that you're going to have one outcome
[Music]
okay and why complete positivity rather
than positivity well systems combine
using the tensor product in quantum
mechanics and we want to be able to
share entangled systems between the
parties and we want to maintain
positivity so we request complete
positivity
so in the quantum causal modelling
frameworks you've seen this in eric's
talk and also in
john's talk and now in mind we use this
isomorphism
instead of representing the cpu maps as
a map from an operator on one space to
an operator on the other space we put
those two spaces together by the tensor
product and we represent the map as a
matrix on that combined space
why do we do that
it's really just mathematical
convenience
i can't i mean i have thought about
whether there's some deep philosophical
reason why that's a good thing to do i
don't think so i think it just means
that
we can perform the trace operation so
that we can um you know trace out part
of a channel and and get identity on the
other part of the channel so the
trojankoski isomorphism is just to make
that explicit when you're dealing with
the matrices
although i'd be interested to hear in
the question if there's anyone in the
quantum community that can think of
anything deeper than that
okay so as i said before nodes
are
defined by these possibility spaces for
the many ways a quantum state can change
as a result of a local intervention and
the nodes of the graph are then
associated with regions where we can
perform these quantum instruments so or
interventions so just think of
instruments and interventions as
interchangeable so as i said
interventions are characterized by
quantum instruments they represent the
collection of all possible events that
can be observed given a specific choice
of probing the system like choosing a
particular measurement outcome doing a
unitary for example so that's a
deterministic
instrument so if you perform a unitary
gate
if you
prepare a system and then
do a transformation and then measure it
you can also represent that
using these cp maps and cptp maps
so mechanisms are responsible for the
evolution of the the state from the
cause to effect nodes um
we can ask you know we can go
i guess philosophically if you want to
in the same way as you do in the
classical case you can say well let's
assume that there's some underlying
deterministic
causal structure that generates the
correlations and the reason that it's
indeterministic is because there's some
noise you can do a kind of similar thing
where you say well it's unitary
operators that are responsible for the
causal mechanisms so you might have you
know out of alice's lab we have you know
row she performs some operation
we then apply the map to rho so you get
some new state
and then
during the
trip to bob's lab there's some evolution
that occurs
and
you end up with sigma a new state coming
into bob's lab
but if we assume that there is this
existence of unmodeled noise and noise
in the same way as you do in the
classical case you don't want it to be
correlated if it's correlated noise then
it's going to gen it's going to like
kind of act like a common cause and it's
going to undermine your your principle
of independent causal mechanisms you're
going to have causal mechanisms that
that can be correlated so if you assume
that there's unmodeled local noise then
the causal mechanisms are also
represented we just use the cptp maps
there's a slight difference of a
transpose and as eric said in his talk
it's really just to keep when you're
accounting for probabilities
it helps things work out neatly
so causal structure itself is defined by
combinations of causal mechanisms these
quantum channels
that connect the nodes and are
responsible for generating correlations
between them
so we can define a positive
semi-definite matrix w which we call the
process matrix on the tensor product of
all the input and output hilbert spaces
of the nodes and we call this the
process matrix so all the information
regarding the way the different channels
connect the nodes in our dag is
encapsulated in this process matrix
i put a little star there because i call
it the process matrix
but this this is an object in quantum
information that's come up in different
contexts and it's called different
things so i called it process matrix
because i came across this object i'm
working with fabio who was part of
chasslav brookner and
onyenareshkov originally wrote this
paper on indefinite causal order
um this is relevant to julia's talk
where um you imagine a space of process
matrices where you don't require this
independent causal mechanism idea you
say okay all we're going to have is
local quantum mechanics to be true where
you perform interventions but but
anything goes outside those local labs
and if anything goes and and you just
have sensible constraints on the process
like it needs to be um
positive semi-definite and you need to
be able to if
all the probabilities need to sum to one
etcetera if you have those constraints
then it allows for some more exotic
things
like the indefinite causal order the
quantum switch where you have a quantum
degree of freedom that kind of switches
between different mechanisms so the
process matrix allows for all those
possibilities but in the quantum causal
modeling framework that i'm presenting
here we're limiting ourselves to the
subset
where the causal mechanisms are
independent
but there is also the quantum comb
formalism julio hirabella and the group
at pavia use that it's the same object
as a process matrix the process tensor
kevin modi who's a physicist at
melbourne and monash his also uses this
object
and i think his work's often overlooked
in the quantum causal modeling community
because typically what they do is they
just look at a single quantum system at
multiple times where you're you're doing
interventions and then looking at the
way there's correlation and
non-markovian effects um but it really
is the same kind of object that we use
um and so i'd encourage anyone who's
interested in quantum calls or modelling
from the quantum community is to to keep
an eye on cabin stuff they're really
prolific they put out a new paper every
three months or so and then i think john
and rob speckins and those groups
refer to this subject as the quantum
state quantum causal state i think
correct me if i'm wrong ellie is that
right i'm cool and state
but i'm going to call it the process
matrix for the remainder of the talk
um
so the important point is that if all
the relevant quantum causes
are included in your model then the
process matrix should decompose into a
fixed set of independent quantum
channels
and the structure will hold regardless
of the interventions that you do at each
node so we retain this intervention in
variant property that you have in in
classical models and we will call this
process markovian
so how do we attach probabilities to
this story
well as you may or may not know there is
a born rule for how you attach
probabilities when you have single
quantum systems so if you have a single
quantum system that you prepare in a
quantum state row then the probability
of getting a particular outcome is given
by the trace of the measurable
measurement operator and the density
matrix of that state that you present
the process rule is a generalization of
this so what it says is that the
probability for a sequence of events so
a sorry a set of events at your nodes
is given by
the maps associated with the
interventions that you choose
tensor product
with the process matrix and then you
take the trace and that gives you this
joint probability so correlations are
just multi-linear functions of the
completely
positive maps at each node is that 15 or
10 or 15 good okay
um is it a unique rule uh yes if you
believe in non-contextuality and
contextuality if you think that's
important you can prove this um one way
to say it is that if a cp map can be
realized by two different instruments so
if you've got one kind of measurement
another kind of measurement and you've
got one cp map that's shared by those
two different instruments
then
the probability with which you assign
should be independent of the instrument
that you use
if you want to understand more about
that you can read this paper
but but for me that says this is the
appropriate rule to to use in this
situation
so if all the correlations are
determined by causal mechanisms it
implies a set of linear constraints and
it literally is that tracing out
different sub systems
and getting um kind of partial traces
and marginalization
of the process and this is what presents
us with the opportunities defining
analogs of the markov condition and
faithfulness
so now we get to the causal discovery
luckily because i've got 15 minutes left
so these were some possums that got into
our optical experiment in queensland one
day
but the thing with causal discovery is
we know that the structure of the dag is
contained within this process matrix so
how do you get it
how do you get the numbers to put in
that matrix you actually have to do
lots and lots of instruments you have to
perform lots of interventions at each
node how many well it scales like
everything in quantum mechanics it
scales really unpleasantly so we have to
use these things informationally
complete instruments you can think of
them as as you have to do enough
operations to kind of span the hilbert
space that you're exploring the tensor
product hilbert space and so the scaling
is exponential in the number of nodes so
every time you add another node to your
dag
then you have to do a heap more
operations
uh
so any markovian process is complete
composed of three kinds of tensor um
factors the input channels the
intermediate channels and then the
output channels where you you know it's
like a measurement you're actually
discarding the system and so the way the
causal discovery algorithm works is it
actually looks for this order event by
tracing out starting at the top looking
for identity on an output and then once
you find which nodes are last
you then
take them out and then you look for
identity on the next set and you trace
them out and you do this kind of
piecewise until you get to the the
causal inputs
so the input to the causal discovery
algorithm which christina giamatsi and
fabio costa developed in 2018 christine
is a
postdoc at the university of technology
sydney now
and she developed an algorithm which you
can download for free
from the from github it you need to
input the process matrix you also need
to input the number of systems that
you're working with and the dimensions
of them
and then it will determine first of all
is the process causally ordered and what
i mean by that is are there independent
mechanisms or is there like a switch if
there's some quantum degree of freedom
that is switching between different
mechanisms the algorithm will say sorry
can't go any further
so if it's causally ordered
if it's not causally ordered it will
reject if it is causally ordered then
the next thing is it will set output the
sets of nodes that are that can't signal
to each other that are independent
and then it will check if all quantum
variables are included if all quantum
variables are included then it can
output a unique dag
if there's not so if there is some
non-markovianity
it will tell you there is
non-microbiality but unfortunately it
can't tell you where it is
so it just it just says there is a
quantum hidden common cause but we there
is no algorithm yet
to identify where that is
so would you ever use this well for
small numbers of systems where you can
actually get the process matrix by doing
your tomography it's useful so this is
kind of state-of-the-art quantum
internet at the moment it's got three
nodes
um so at the moment it is still in the
realms of where figuring out what the
process matrix is is not terribly
onerous and perhaps this could be useful
for verifying the order of local
operations and if you're needing to make
lots of operations fairly quickly the
connectivity structure possibly um
but i think what we will see i mean you
know quantum technology is a
multi-billion dollar industry and we
will see more and more complex quantum
engineered networks and systems in the
future and this kind of cool technology
ultimately
i think could benefit from some
ability to do causal inference so to be
able to identify
when you've got quantum noise for
example that's non-markovian and
affecting your experiment when you've
got um
you know an order of operations that you
you want to be able to verify
when you want to be able to verify the
connectivity structure if it's dynamic
and changing
and so in those situations we really
want to try and think about is this some
other way that we can estimate the
process matrix without needing to do
this exponential number of interventions
and so we've just had a few kind of
little
gentle probes and some interesting
directions to think about this
one is well let's just construct a
database of process matrices so let's
just simulate them and then use machine
learning to classify to distinguish
between them so then you know you you
you're in your situation and perhaps you
have partial knowledge of your process
matrix you don't do all the
informationally complete instruments but
with machine learning can you then
adjudicate between which you know which
processes you that you're closest to
um
so
uh how much time have i got to there
like two minutes or something
i mean it's all good okay um so
uh we did this in
um a simple setup we just had a single
quantum system it was a qubit and we
applied three unit trees at different
time steps and then we did a measurement
so ordinarily to reconstruct the process
you'd have to do kind of measurements
either side of each of the unit trees
but we what we wanted to do is to see
whether we could learn anything about
the process in the absence of that
tomographically complete information
so we just simulated a heap of different
processes with different either
microbial processes with different
dimensions so two four six dimensions
and then a whole lot of non-markovian
processes
of different dimensions and then we just
threw it all into random forest to see
whether it could
estimate
if you're just given
the
the measurement outputs conditioned on
which unit trees
so
what you feed the algorithm is i did
this unit tree it's step one this unit
tree at step two this unit tree at step
three
and here's the probabilities of the
outcomes that i got then the algorithm
says
you have a non-markovian environment of
four dimensions
or you have a markovian environment of
two dimensions
how useful is that it doesn't tell you
exactly what the problem is but it kind
of tells you the scope of the problem
you know you've got a really big
non-markovian environment that's
affecting things that's something that
might be useful
the algorithm also return a construction
in case it tells you look
no
it should but it doesn't yet next stage
um
uh yeah so that's just what i said
um and then the next step was to say
well could we do this kind of from using
well control well-controlled experiments
instead so you know could you have a
situation where for example
you know the you know the physical setup
and then you simulate
physically using your experimental
equipment you kind of simulate markovian
correlations or you simulate
non-microbial examples so you introduce
a kind of
extra cubit that's going to generate
correlations and then you use that
experimental data to classify future
experiments where you don't know you
know where where the the um
the kind of hidden common cause for
example is unknown
and so um we did an experiment with
kalmudi
where we did that just characterizing
non-markovian classical noise in a
quantum optics experiment
so there is some other work um
gao kevin modi and paletti put out a
paper where they use tensor
network-based machine learning so tensor
networks
are a kind of machine learning that was
inspired from the quantum community
it is essentially also a supervised
learning technique so they generated a
database
i guess the key thing that's interesting
here is that you you can represent the
process in a more compressed form using
matrix product operators and there is a
bit of a tradition not in the quantum
causal literature but in other quantum
information literature and using matrix
product operators as a way of
representing um quantum processes in a
more compact way so that's a another
area that
needs to be
explored further
and then julio kirabella's group has
also put out an algorithm
and as far as i can tell it really just
follows the algorithm that i presented
earlier that christina presented but
instead of
getting the process matrix by doing all
the informationally complete
measurements
you actually choose which order you do
the measurements in
based on that tracing out procedure so
you start with nodes and then you do the
tracing out and see if on each other
node you get the identity and when you
find a node where you get the identity
you go okay so they're causally
connected
so it's a kind of systematic way of
reproducing that process matrix
the nice thing is that they're able to
prove by doing it this way that if
there's low noise if it's low rank it's
fast basically then you can do this
fairly efficiently
okay
so i guess you know i hope what i'm
leaving you with is all these open
questions like this is a matrix that we
need to be able to estimate
there i'm sure are many techniques in
machine learning that are better
motivated maybe sequence to sequence
learning things like that maybe g flow
nets where you you know you're learning
a graph and a sequence i'm sure there
are there are better motivated machine
learning techniques that we can use
there's a lot of structure in the
process matrix and in the methods that i
described we're not really exploiting
that structure
um
there are i'm sure methods that we can
use to do that
no one's thought about school-based
methods in this context at all
that's something that should be explored
and and there are probably physical
scenarios that we're more likely to come
across in quantum technology that are
going to place constraints on the
process that will make it easier to
learn and discover
and with that i thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
questions
thanks thanks for the really great talk
um i was wondering if there's sort of
related to your score based
question but at the end
is there a sense of um goodness of fit
given so if you fix a structure yeah and
the process matrix decomposes in the way
according to that structure i guess i'm
i don't as someone who doesn't know what
the data actually looks like i'm not
really sure what it means to say i have
like an estimate of that process matrix
w hat and i want to know whether it's a
good estimate given the structure that
i've just
yeah
it's a great question and i think that
um well no one's really explored it i'm
sure that there are measures that would
accurately reflect a goodness of fit i
suppose one way to think about it is
with christina's algorithm
there is a tunable parameter which kind
of accepts a degree of noise and because
what we're doing is we're tracing out um
part of your process matrix and looking
for identity and looking for that kind
of perfectly and obviously that there's
some noise limit that you might want to
tolerate
and you don't you want to be able to
tolerate it locally rather than kind of
smeared out over the whole causal
structure
so there's probably something in terms
of using school-based methods
where it's a score kind of for each
local area rather than for the overall
process because i would worry if you
just used a school-based method for the
overall process that you might the noise
might end up kind of being smeared out
and you'd miss a hidden degree of
freedom does that make sense
yeah insofar as i understand anything
but um
but yeah but maybe because it decomposes
in this local way that it's like
basically like something given the
parents yes then maybe you only need
that local yes yes i'm sure that's right
i'm sure that's correct that's probably
the right way to do it yeah thank you
thank you um can you say a little bit
more about um the under determination of
the structure so you you said somewhere
along the uh during the talk that
under certain conditions you would get
the unique dag
out
presumably because you're doing all of
these inter
sort of interventions there but then in
the non-markovian case then you can't
say much so could you i don't have a
good sense of this sort of space could
you explain that a little bit more what
the underdetermination looks like then
structurally yeah so i think
i think it's probably possible
for you well let me think about it
um
i think the worry is that uh
so here's the way i'd put it
in the process matrix so as you know the
process matrix is composed of these
tensor products of of these local
channels
so it should be
if you have just one node
you know sorry one hidden quantum node
that's correlated with maybe two other
nodes and you don't know
then it shouldn't affect so much of your
process matrix it should only affect
those parts where those tensor factors
are involved
but
if you had a node for example that was
correlated with everything in your model
it would change every aspect of the
process matrix it may only change it
slightly
so therefore i guess there is that under
determination
um
uh but you know as daniel saying maybe
there's enough of the structure there
that with some thresholding you know if
you assume some thresholding of
of
how far from the identity you're willing
to tolerate um maybe you can resolve
some of that under determination
that makes sense
so just one uh really nice talk one uh
question i had relating to jonathan's
talk this morning was he had these
graphs and then when the operator was
invertible he could flip them around and
obviously from a kind of causal
discovery elem uh view that was really
weird because
non-collider interplayed it so i i don't
know whether this may be a very basic
question for the
quantum people but can you
know it's not a basic question at all
and i'm not sure i can say anything
intelligent but i'll give it a go
um
so i think the unitary story is
reversible
and if you
you know if you assume that the causal
mechanisms underlying everything is
unitary
um
then
what what is it that gives you the
causal directionality
and i would say it is the interventions
it's the possibility of interventions
and the fact that when you do an
intervention it signals and that the
interventions are cp maps and cptp maps
and they are can be indeterministic
so
that's kind of where the indeterminism
comes in and that's why you don't
have that problem i would say there is a
difference between so john's formalism
so as i said our process matrix has to
decompose into these tensor factors
and for him he also allows
channels to be commuting rather than
necessarily factorizing to the tensor
product so his definition of of
markovianity is broader it captures
commuting channels but i'm not sure how
you do causal discovery in that context
which is why i'm kind of still stuck
here and i think even when you have
commuting channels
um
you still need to think about so what's
the intervention that i can do to
disambiguate and i think once you start
thinking about where you do the
interventions and what you have to do
um it kind of naturally falls back into
that tensor factorization language
um so that's why i kind of default back
to that even though
john's version is more general i'm not
sure whether that has has implications
on that reversibility statement john's a
person to ask okay great thanks
maybe just i wanted to ask a follow-up
to this and then i'll give you the
microphone i was just wondering if
in the attempt to make the model more
strong to noise and etc
is there any limitation that one
shouldn't do to this to this
intervention notes for instance you know
maybe
sending pairs of entangled particles
that could perhaps alter the causal
model underneath
and
so are you asking
um so certainly there would be i guess
if you did something like a switch
if you do anything and and i think a lot
of the experiments that you've designed
and the work that you've done it would
be difficult to un uncover the processes
because what you are doing is you
in a sense the this independence of
causal mechanisms is no longer there
so i think
i think you're right i think it does
make it difficult if and so there
probably is a restricted set of of
operations that you can do
um
so i think if you use if you have any
kind of qubit that's going to
you know change your causal structure
if you're conditioning on that then i
think you'll find it difficult to use
this methodology yeah yeah thanks and
just before isaac asked his question i
did forget to make one comment in other
work
there will be other work appearing on
the archive soon so isaac is working on
causal discovery um quantum causal
discovery using category theory so keep
an eye out for that anyway
question
uh all right so um i think
well there's there's a problem that i'm
not uh very familiar with um modi's
stuff on quantum non-markovianity but uh
a thing that um
uh
that i was discussing with ellie the
other day is from around the time when
you first wrote the um
the paper with costa this uh
these experiments from uh perimeter
where um
they
uh were
they were figuring out how much of a
correlation between two time-separated
quantum systems uh was due to
um prior entanglement
and
there's like there's a kind of
in some sense special quantum effect
where um a common cause from prior
entanglement
helps you can tell more about common
cause that was due to prior entanglement
then you can in a classical setting tell
about common cause that was due to
ordinary correlation of random variables
you talking about cut your reads what
yes yes okay yep and so i was i was
wondering whether um
uh like how much of the non-markovianity
or or how much of the causal discovery
um protocols uh
rely on the general insight
uh from that work which was basically
that
when you have a common cause scenario
the effective process relating the two
things
is not a quantum channel it's something
that's not um completely positive
um
i'm not sure of the question that you're
asking the question is whether the
causal discovery um protocols rely on
this uh
on this
phenomenon or not so when you say
phenomenon this phenomenon that so
insofar as
there is a kind of
similarity between
temporal and spatial
that i think catcher reed captures in
that work then yeah i think that's
correct
if that's what you're referring to
so i mean what i mean is that in general
um i can talk a lot about quantum
tomography without talking about what
katie reed did yes and so and so the
question is can i talk about the
approximation from partial tomography uh
that you're doing can i talk about that
without talking about katya reed's work
or or is it involved
yeah it's been a long time since i've
read that paper so i'm probably not i'm
probably not going to give the correct i
mean
uh
the main finding from that paper that
you're referring to is what
exactly the main finding is that there
are quantum scenarios in which
you can uh you can tell
you can tell uh how much uh
non-markovianity so to speak is involved
in your um
uh in your effective process and the way
in which you do this um
is by finding parts of your effective
process that are not completely positive
so they are not allowed
quantum processes okay yes definitely
there is a relationship okay yeah
gotcha
so thank you again and
[Music]
[Applause]
and
so given we are a bit over time should
we still take a break or should we just
go straight to the
quick break okay then a five minutes
break
okay